The Mask mandates were actually the best
thing to ever happen to luxury Brands
and here's why during the pandemic there
were lines out the stores because they
would only let two people in the store
at a time but here's what's crazy after
the pandemic was over they still kept
the lines no one else did why when
people wait a longer period of time for
something what happens one they paid in
time to get in the store so they just
paid a cost and so the likelihood that
they buy actually goes up the other
thing that happens is it becomes even
more scarce or the psychological
appearance of even higher demand while
every other store let people back in and
try to do business as normal retail
luxury stores realize this actually
further enhanced the buying percentage
and the average ticket of the people who
walked in their stores and they have
kept it and I doubt they'll change it